now there's one disease that is so
ignored yet so common yet rarely tested
that you need to know about in fact this
will explain a lot about your health so
I'm going to go through all the other
problems that this one thing has created
before I tell you what it is let's see
if you can guess it number one this
problem will cause you to urinate
excessively through the night okay
number one number two it'll make you
tired number three it'll make you crave
carbs through the day and cause you not
to be able to go up for a long period of
time without eating it is the thing
behind your belly fat and a slow
metabolism or a set point where you just
can't seem to lose as past a certain
weight it's the thing behind a fatty
liver okay a non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease it is the root cause of your
brain fog your lack of concentration
your mood being low forward in a state
of anxiety or depression or being highly
irritable it is the reason behind
dementia and forgetfulness this thing
increases your risk for cancer for heart
attacks for clots for strokes it's the
thing behind nerve problems like
autonomic nervous system dysfunction as
well as peripheral neuropathy in the
bottom of your feet or the palm of your
hands it also will greatly lower your
immune system increasing your risk for
getting infections it's behind lowered
HDL high LDL specifically the dangerous
LDL with the small dense particle size
it's behind high triglycerides as well
as high cholesterol it's also behind
high blood pressure which collectively
all these symptoms are metabolic
syndrome it's behind polycystical
ovariance syndrome where females start
developing facial hair and get a deeper
voice it's definitely behind diabetes
type two it's behind gallstones all of
these symptoms I just mentioned are
directly coming from this one disease
and that disease is called
hyperinsulinemia
hyper meaning too much of something
insulin meaning insulin anemia meaning
the blood it's too much insulin in your
blood what's really really bizarre is
doctors never focus on this they don't
test it they test your blood sugars your
blood glucose levels Okay now what's
interesting about this High insulin
level is that you can have high insulin
levels for years and not have high blood
sugar okay as you may know what
increases insulin is high carb diets
sugar and also frequent eating right the
question is how is it that some people
can eat so much sugar and have normal
blood glucose an average person consumes
13 added teaspoons of sugar every single
day that's added that has nothing to do
with the other carbohydrates they're
eating okay if we add in the other
carbohydrates which come out to roughly
about 60 or 65 percent of the total
calories we're talking about a half a
pound of sugar a day we're talking about
68.7 teaspoons of sugar that all these
carbohydrates turn into I'm talking
about like the wine I'm talking about
the bread the pasta the cereal the
crackers the juice all of these carbs
turn into
68.7 teaspoons of sugar a day how the
heck can someone ever end up with normal
blood sugars if they're consuming that
much sugar well the answer is insulin
insulin is doing the work behind the
scenes insulin is removing the sugar as
fast as it's going in there to give you
normal blood sugars and so here the
doctors checks your blood sugars oh
you're fine you're healthy but they
didn't check the insulin that's working
like a mad dog pumping out all this
insulin and removing the sugar
converting it to cholesterol and fat and
giving you all these other symptoms
so it really is going to go on for about
15 to 20 years before you start getting
higher sugar because of a condition
called insulin resistance okay see you
have to realize that insulin is just as
toxic as sugar in high amounts and so
the more insulin that your body pumps
out
the more your body is going to protect
itself from all this excess insulin so
it develops insulin resistance okay now
the problem with that is you have
certain parts of your body where you
have very little amounts of insulin okay
and you have other parts that you have
high amounts of insulin and so it's a
double-edged sword because you get all
the negative parts of insulin and you
don't get all the positive parts of
insulin because one of the purposes of
insulin is to help you absorb nutrients
so basically your body is kind of
starving of nutrients it's not able to
absorb amino acids correctly or even
potassium or vitamin D because of this
insulin resistance and then the cells
start to also lack getting fuel like in
the mitochondria or the brain cells so
you start forgetting things you started
having all sorts of problems with your
cells but your blood sugars are
initially normal and then they start to
go out of whack and so this insulin
resistance condition is a protective
mechanism it's helping you survive and
in the process your body has to make
more insulin to compensate for this
resistance it's kind of like let's say
you had a barn in your backyard in
Sunfire and you have someone pouring
gasoline on it right but you have
someone else putting water out on it
right and there's an unlimited amount of
gasoline and they keep putting gasoline
on and someone else has to keep coming
with water to put this this flame out
eventually the more gasoline you're
going to put it's going to start on fire
and the whole thing is going to be burnt
up that's exactly what is happening with
the average person you've got all this
insulin being pumped out at first
it's able to handle this these blood
sugars but eventually it's not and so
the person ends up being a diabetic the
doctor rarely changes their diet and
removes the source of the high insulin
it's the high carb diet or the frequent
meals so here they are taking medication
artificially now lower the blood sugars
and take Metformin to lower the insulin
resistance while they're consuming all
these carbs the requirement for
medication keeps going higher and higher
and they keep getting worse and worse
and worse until they have gangrene in
their feet and they have amputations
they go blind so it's a very very simple
test that I highly recommend the next
time you go to your doctor ask for a
fasting insulin test okay of course you
don't have to wait for that test you can
just start correcting it immediately all
you have to do is start the ketogenic
plan and start doing intermittent
fasting and your insulin is going to
come down and you are going to be able
to get rid of a lot of problems there
are hundreds of thousands of people
worldwide that are on keto and doing
intermittent fasting and getting rid of
a lot of problems in fact we have over 6
000 success stories on our website you
can go to drburg.com and start reading
them but that's just a small sliver
there are many many other people I just
recently started collecting success
stories I wish I would have started at
the very very beginning but there's a
really good book by Joseph craft MD that
I highly recommend taking a look at and
I will put that link down below which
backs up all the things I'm talking
about but for you right now the best
thing to do is get on keto with
intermittent fasting
this video will explain exactly how to
do it in a very simple way check it out